this is better I'm actually cut my
salary cheap I'm actually happy cut my
salary by 75% but money's not everything
unless you have a good yeah no I mean at
the end of the day Papa yeah again it's
Friday it's got Tokyo Friday
it's copia Friday we got our boys we got
a boy blue ice we got my captain Mike
Catherwood my fave Stevie's in my face
now I got good news and bad news
yeah I woke up and I get a little tweet
from variety mag yeah you had your
picture on I'm like oh hell yeah what
was in that's Joker to another cameo
like yeah I do news madness good news
bad news good news is you're gonna have
more time give more time to commit to
firing the kid yes and stand up yeah
whatever else you want to do all that
stuff bad news bad news I need you to
bear down and you've been what happened
what happens you your spin-off show
school this can't that's canceled guess
today wait a minute okay so my show has
been cancelled because I know take it
easy I don't want you to get old classic
fine you're fine
I'm puppet I'm gonna take 75% of salary
I may have taken a 75% salary cut do I
have two mortgages yes do I have a lot
of other stuff like alimony and child
support of course I hate to do more bad
news good deli and I can't lend you
money and and this is where and this is
what's interesting about that comment
cuz I got because I can force you guys
to I said that's Italy I just saw him
this morning I go hey I'll ruin you yeah
your tags are so funny like I start
because I text Brian I said I said on
the article that it's just getting
cancelled I know dude sucks but it was
likes worse Italy and I aren't gonna
give any more money
you know Brian replied you
son-of-a-bitch as I started doing this
[ __ ] bit I'm not good well I'm coming
after you I think you can physically
force Chris to give you money I robbed
them really sure you have to stand no
chance of doing anything to Brendan no
Papa got any gun pick it up
no they it's ready though I'm get my
money Wade go with your earned it Emily
well I'm gonna be now I'm not gonna
podcast Monday oh so my dad yo see my
mom is the other 82 show just yet I know
and then you're missing this exact on
Tuesday I'm gonna have to replace
already started don't replace me because
I need money I need money now
oh yeah for your Monday did Kovac have
our audiences as well yeah can we cut
your audience because most most viewing
viewership when I'm saying I mean for
daddy the belts gonna be a little tight
for a while at 53 daddy's got to tighten
his belt how many seasons in school we
had to and we were we did we were number
two in the ratings we were crushing the
ratings and they just I think it's two
things it's it's one is well no it's not
two things is one thing I think trying
to get you know production going with
all these ridiculous restrictions they
don't know how to do it insurance and
everything so especially not in LA just
yeah they were just like sorry look at
this Adam Goldberg 35 episodes now yeah
35 now now by the way daddy used to be a
pretty staple on the Goldbergs Cole
Brooks coming back yeah give me fine
there right yeah I might get a cop why
wouldn't you want one coach Mel did they
use the same crew what's that did they
just show you the same Joe
yeah maybe spot of five calls us and
gives us a hundred million dollars yeah
why not oh why not right why not the
fight I don't get what Rogan and it gets
all the money and they can't [ __ ]
they can't shuffle over a little cash
hey that's not it that's not actually
not a bad point though because obviously
Joe's the guy who's opening the door but
that it's not gonna end and stop there
I mean Spotify is going to make a press
I think they made the I'm ethically made
the right decision choosing Joe Rogan as
the really know it was a genius to stay
underpaid but that um you know it's
obviously gonna work out well for them
and that's gonna open up doors to a lot
of punch so competition is good you know
for the business you don't want YouTube
to control your destiny or night to know
you and you want competition it's funny
with any of this stuff the blowback we
don't know what's happening well we
don't know what the ramifications are
gonna be from this kovat thing a year or
two years from now some of its gonna be
good some of its gonna be bad maybe all
of it'll be bad maybe all of it'll be
good I think I think it's I think it's
become a memory for people obviously
people who are affected that lost loved
ones stuff like that that never does way
but in general I think when I look back
in like dude remember we're a lockdown
at where mass shooting where all the
press said you were gonna die Georgia
says but we don't have any of that
problem but reserve yeah where Florida
is just like wait there's a there's an
issue going around like the floor has no
idea yeah well they would have sorted
they were like I love that man but the
governor was targeted
yeah governor said yeah let's just
protect very old people wait the data
says if you're 80 and over you're in
trouble so let's take care of those and
yeah that's what we got yeah the media
but the governor goes were eight weeks
in what the [ __ ] were you guys saying
where is the death what our death row
count has been going down you [ __ ]
everyone that's open its finger but CNN
and all them have a narrative that they
have to guard it's really strange too
and um I don't find it strange that
people have political leanings I don't
find it strange that people are gonna
like choose sides and take teams it's
been happening people like to assume
that's but this is a new thing yeah I
you know I remember when I was a kid
like Reagan era there was a big division
in the country I mean there hated him
many liberals absolutely despised Ronald
Reagan and and alternatively though a
huge portion this country was so
invigorated by Ronald Reagan and this
idea of like you know power to the USA
let's bring let's bring up you know
traditional moral values and and make
the economy boom and and the military
and and his his incredibly regardless of
what you feel about Ronald Reagan is
perfect but his his incredibly powerful
stance on the age of glass no stand the
idea of standing in front of the podium
and saying you know tear down this wall
I mean mr. Gorbachev directly addressing
the USS I mean he was he was just he was
an incredibly powerful figure he was an
actor you know he'd been an actor let me
start so he was a movie star your call
movie star then he went to they became
the governor here actually became a
really successful businessman then he
was again the governor stud and then the
president I states if you ever get when
I was younger
watch his speeches when he was in town
halls or dinner when he's trying to get
elected he because remember Carter was
kind of a very kind of a yeah Reagan was
so he was big and dramatic and an old
school and he'd the way he would
emphasize things he had a great sense of
humor here dude yes yeah there you got a
vote for a guy with it it's just like
you only hear negative things now like
the big things that make the publicity
is more spending this you don't hear do
you like on CNN MSNBC you find in a New
York Times but that alternatively which
I think is causing it you know even
bigger problem is that you uniformly
only hear how foul sees file cheese
making mistakes and and all these great
positive outlooks from Fox News and The
Wall Street Journal and it only creates
this bigger divide and that's my that's
my big concern is that but we've been
through this right like Vietnam War
think about the divide during that but
here's the problem we understood that
did we it was a war it took place over
here we didn't know what men were dying
no no the the war itself like they
semantically the war itself I think is
very confusing because it was just weird
quagmire but the idea of an American or
malavika merican citizen is like are our
boys are being drafted and they're going
to war in Vietnam people are dying war
is terrible
what do we do this is every single day I
try I'd cry to be checked in I try to be
someone who thinks I can I want to know
what's going on that's right every
single [ __ ] day everything is so
vague everything is so confusing and
you're just like what why I'm wait I'm
wearing a mask why what so when where
can I go where can I go and every day
everything just becomes more and more
[ __ ] gray and there's no you know
what I'm saying like with 911 my wife
and I were talking about it like 9/11
was awful it was [ __ ] mm so
devastating but you understood it yeah
you said this happened at this time I
watched those planes fly and people are
dead [ __ ] man we better rally together
this is so nebulous that I think it's
creating an even more like worth we're
looking for comfort and all fire comfort
in these teams and the [ __ ] thing is
that's crazy is that there is no other
team except for us
team human and the [ __ ] elites like
if you have this notion that if you're
anti-trump and you're in your
anti-republican I get it that's your
business but to create this narrative
where your anti-trump and your anti
things that he does so alternatively
what Nancy Pelosi humor are doing is in
my best interest and therefore the
people you're [ __ ] highs nuns
everyone everyone at the highest level
is colluding with special interest
groups and high-end and big corporations
and does not at all give a [ __ ] about
what is going on with us the people you
know and it's like
did you see Biden I know it's incredible
so you shouldn't you see Biden with
Charlemagne then that was insane no I
didn't see he goes if you don't know who
to vote for or you guys if you don't
know not to vote for Trump then you
ain't black
that's what Charlemagne said no no to
Charlemagne and troubling you if you're
still confused about who to vote for
then you're not black and I went Joe
bites it but he's kind of putting some
flavor in the whole interviewer like
yeah what does that mean Charlemagne
went Adam didn't let him off the hook
went Adam does I see that yeah you can
see here there's a little clip of it and
Joan but didn't Joe Biden does I spent
40 years trying to take out Joe Biden
like what is happening dude
are you a robot you can't do that the
black media you might do that the white
medium black maybe because my wife has
to go on at 6 o'clock okay oh oh I'm in
trouble
listen you gotta come see us when you
come to New York VP Biden well it's a
long way until November we got more
questions you got more questions without
telling if you have a problem figuring
out whether you're for mere Trump and
you ain't black they don't have nothing
to do with Trump it has to do with the
same what it's really hard time I was
struggling just whoa hey
yes sir lingos Adam that's [ __ ] weird
left-wing race-baiting [ __ ] it's so
[ __ ] silly and I here's another thing
oftentimes charlemagne he gets really
well-known for like a lot of his like
viral clips where he's going hard on
someone and so I think people make this
association that that's what he is a
just he's just like edge Lord
Charlemagne is so [ __ ] smart measure
he's such a valuable and an important
broadcaster he's like there's not very
many people like Charlemagne he's so
[ __ ] good look Joe Rogan for black
people like he's eligible he's like he
really you know he won't back down from
places easily from you know mental
no I'm not bidding you know like I've
been investing room as the guy at like
radio events but I I'm such a big fan I
I like especially coming from that
industry you know like the pressures
that go into not being like him yeah
every step of the way like Jesus I
started on Wendy Willy and thank you for
him to ascend the ranks in popularity
the way he has while also maintaining
this this really like unashamedly even
and balance and wealth and many
thoughtful zazen take you on really good
when your dad honest like I what I
notice about him is that he hasn't
kissed anybody's ass when he was
interviewing Kanye West the hard
questions he was posed by the interview
I one doesn't like minute you keep
talking about Trump I'm not for what are
you gonna do
the black button he's like going out and
crashing biden's was it ready
I might was not ready thought was gonna
be softballs no sure lingers hard to
meet people like Charlotte so that's
that's a good posture all forget being
Republican or Democrat how about just
being practical when you get down to the
level of detail to solve real problems
it's all that ideology goes out the
window you got to get practical that's
why I find that people who have to like
make a business run you ever notice how
people have to make a restaurant run and
so they tend to not want to talk about
politics they just want their practical
they tend to want to be like look that
there's their moderate they tend to be
sort of like in the middle kind of
sometimes over here something anytime
you run a business anytime you it it
seems to me that people who talk for a
living like media people they have the
luxury of being all the way over here or
all the way over there and and the
roundel is I can't do not only media
people but oftentimes professional
intellectuals and I think that's a big
problem with like that's factor demux is
that obviously some of them most of them
deserve tremendous respect for their
intellect and the fact that they've
committed their life to learning
something to such a great extent but the
problem is is that for instance
economics if you're an economics teacher
at the highest level if you're teaching
at Harvard Business School or Wharton
School of Business you see this much
you've never run a business yeah
everything kind of exists it's like
being a martial arts teacher and you've
never in teaching self-defense but
you've never been in a real fight right
you see that Alzheimer or being like a
master at a certain kind of karate or
whatever and then like and then talking
about MMA you know there's something
practical about the one things I love
about MMA is like when I when I saw yeah
you're a Rodriguez I always talk about
this so Brendan I saw him kicking and
doing ours I'm a Taekwondo guy so I'm
watching him do all these like kicks and
stuff and I go but for real I go yeah he
was so good I go it's gonna be really
hard to solve that problem cuz he can
stand on the outside and we'll kick you
roundhouse kick you and all that and
Brendan said don't give him the Frankie
I don't do that I go I don't know house
Frank Egan and Brennan said that doesn't
work on the on the on the higher up guys
and I couldn't understand it but unless
you understand that he broke up Frankie
broke him right but butcher couldn't you
took three years you know right away
right away why cuz Brennan had practical
experience having to solve those
problems I got I might have FICO kicks
but I've got you you just you don't
understand unless you've been doing it
for a long time yeah you got a practical
understanding and then you can you can
recognize he saw that your ear egg race
is really exciting wonderful but he also
saw the guys young and still has
deficits in this game because he's not
an MMA fighter yet not a complete MMA
fighter but I also think that's why I
like if someone criticizes a fighter
that's why you'll see me get off stick
out for me I'm like doo doo doo because
you've never made that walk you really
haven't been tough you know I said
that's like you're talking a soldier
anytime at the time you know you did
tours over in Iraq he never did him
looking like what are you talking about
you're so far out that's not how it
works man I said that Brendan I said my
buddy my buddy who used to spar with
with Shawn Porter cuz he came up in that
circuit and I said my buddy I heard from
other people that he gave Shawn Porter
fits and and Brennan said Brian Shawn
Porter seven-time world champion hold on
he made that walk seven times you got to
stop saying that because and the reason
you gotta stop saying that is because
your friend might have done that in
practice sparring he never made that
walk and then you see a fighter Oh spats
and you go oh I gotta shut the [ __ ] up I
gotta shut the [ __ ] up cuz that guy
finds a way to win it's such a different
animal and so I would say you can take
that example and apply it to economics
like don't you apply politics too
because I like we invited sighs yes you
politicians and we know how sleazy and
stuff like that but no sir Paul you're
right I'm sure you know if someone can
look like Kay do the nitty-gritty Asst
you pass this and if you do this you're
gonna get this return like I told you I
talked to a woman who's in local
politics she started talking to me and
she goes you know you're talking
I was so naive she goes it's great that
you think that if you're a Democratic
candidate or if you're even moderate
you're not getting elected unless you
catered a big Union it's not happy there
are certain realities Aaron lies the
problem because I think you you bring up
a good point doesn't that apply to
politics yes and no yeah I think it
applies to politics and how its
practiced today because we don't see how
the sausage is made correct it doesn't
apply to
how the three branches of government
were initially developed in this country
where they were to be representative of
the people yeah and it's like hey this
is kind of a silly idea but I believe
something I was thinking about as I was
so disappointed in the fact that you
know the American political system has
gotten to that point but I feel like in
order to become a successful politician
in this country you have to be Batman
you have to kill some in that and what I
mean by that is it like this if this
ethical egoism where it's like you have
to be a sniper you're all about yourself
Batman was not this philanthropic guy he
was fueled by vengeance yeah he was a
billionaire who [ __ ] chicks and he's
like I want to build the best cars and
the best tools the only reason I'm going
out to [ __ ] Gotham is because they
[ __ ] killed my parents yet and I'm
angry and I'm I like that it's just all
about meat ya know in turn in turn he
did it subsequently did a lot of good
things he probably saved Gotham but but
but my point is is like you have to be
Batman this dark brooding guy who's all
about success and all about his own way
but what we need from a politician is
Superman someone who's this eye this
benevolent door or all devoted to
represent madam said we would like there
might be another way you also might need
less government less politician activity
because Americans can figure [ __ ] out on
their own there's also that yeah
sometimes when you're looking or to
president yeah when you're looking to a
president or personally and I think
everybody in this [ __ ] room
especially Stevie can say that I don't
look to the government i I don't rely on
the government like i I when my TV show
goes away I think I don't have the
government to come in and help me out
with my two mortgages either I don't
have Chris because they're not true
friends the I gotta solve that problem
most Americans are that way or you know
so so it'll be till told what to do yeah
and I don't want the government to come
in with their giant government programs
I don't think they'd do it as well as
free enterprise bureaucracy doesn't
really work where do you read where do
you get most of your info how do you
feed your brain um you go for current
events are for
just light all I mean when you come you
have your like you know let's say for
like like Corona [ __ ] where would you
get your stuff it's hard because III
just I get it I get it from a lot of
sigh I'm someone who's glitters become
as easily as we're prone to reading the
New York Times I am to the Wall Street
Journal and those are like the two main
sources I know that one's more liberal
leaning and ones more um more
conservative but but at least I know
that these are high level journalism and
these are thinkers so you know it's not
gonna be like that's a nice balance so
you gotta write in over that hole the
cable news stuff is the problem at and
as someone who's like I've worked for
CNN I work for NBC Universal right I
remember that and I so I I've seen kind
of behind the curtain and all I'm saying
this isn't a pejorative statement this
isn't to bring down mainstream media but
all these conspiracy theorists who are
out there saying these things you have
to understand it's 100% true that news
programming there's no there's very no
difference between a news program or the
team that went into making Brian's
sitcom yeah because that's there is a
there is a there is a projected
O'Brien's former stick up there's a
there's a clear idea of the message they
want to convey prior to accumulating the
the the news that they want to give
there's a clear narrative and just like
a scriptwriter it has a story that they
want to tell that goes on at major cable
news corporation whether and this isn't
a partisan statement it goes just as
much on to Fox's it does it at and it's
almost unbearable to watch it's getting
just like it's just there I'll watch
both holy okay I get my information from
like you guys the bro side you don't
want fine could be your new source yeah
we might be a better you know you don't
if you if that's where you end it but
you do affect if something here on the
fire kid or Rogen's podcast I'll look
into it
I'd say look into it yeah you know but
are we saying that Eddie's been right
the whole time like like it might be
that Eddie Bravo actually was on to
something here Eddie Bravo and Tim Dylan
got it
oh okay I remember when Eddie like first
off the last fire the last fight
companion the best one ever
Eddie was never been more insane every
one of you trying to regulate that
insane that spark plug separately the
bad get to go yeah well your your kind
of oh oh he'll do that yeah but I rule a
long time ago like a but maybe three or
four months ago like right when the
concerns about the lockdown first
happens so distracted by your shoulders
Eddie said something so that journey
naturally thick muscular kid I'm gonna
have my hands full when we rolled my
hands full
better believe it yeah but your neck
full my [ __ ] oh but your legs look
eminently you know [ __ ] take down a
bowl but keep going Eddie said something
a bit like the beginning of this this
whole thing it that did I always stuck
with me and he said imagine like you
have a friend that says like in a coma
he's in a coma right he wakes up right
now and he goes wait the [ __ ] the
Major League Baseball and the NFL's
[ __ ] clothes and there's no [ __ ] NFL
know any section okay so so there's
millions of people dead right and you're
like no no there's wait wait yeah so
that no one's filming in shows and the
[ __ ] businesses are all closed so
like it's 90 percent of the people have
it right no like like like like 12
percent yeah you know those latest at
7-under 74 years old with no morbidities
you have a ninety-nine point eight
percent chance of being 100 percent fine
yeah you're not gonna die yeah
ninety-nine point eight percent but a
little more than that like that's
[ __ ] nuts yeah and if you say that on
YouTube you might get Pam oh but also
went with their like go kids the reason
we got stopped kids going to school even
though no like 0.001 percent of children
died from Kovac zero they go will cuz
they can get it and give it to their
parents and asymptomatic and they're
figuring out that children can't pass it
on
well and also down for no reason this is
the way I look at it like people are
saying it's so irresponsible to go out
and to reintroduce up north don't wear a
mask
I go no it would be irresponsible to let
your kid go
school and then hang out with his
grandparents
that's what's your response that's right
how about we just make that decision you
know it's like what I see people
tweeting someone else with the you know
a controversial opinion they say my
grandpa could die because of you and
your behavior I go well don't keep like
don't allow your grandpa to be around so
I'm going to see my 80 year old father
it's per his birthday is on on this
Saturday and about some underlying
health issues no but he's there he's it
ain't it he's got you know he could die
if he gets his feast like he got think
he's got a piece he's six foot four
250-pound man holy naw he's a big boy
but he's but he's like just my
Frankenstein big giant but he's a t we
call be a great big much yeah it's Big
Mike Big Mike my phone is Big Mike I've
never called datacom Big Mike he calls
me old bean strange oh whoa Oh be old
bean my name but but it's big my
externship
Big Mike let's see do we have any pics
of him can't see this is not him though
no no oh yeah he's on my Instagram but
the point is the [ __ ] guy I I'm going
there I got a swab I got a I got a kovat
swab I'll find out in a couple days I'll
find out tomorrow
what the [ __ ] Ryan Colin gets oh my god
that's cool oh is that a mix mock-up I
look like an old man you look like Bruce
Willis someone a lot how about my ex
what did you want to talk about I can
smoke show wait if way to [ __ ] that up
Brian anyway the point is the point is
Tom yeah I'm gonna practice safe
distancing he's got a party but I gotta
be I got a yeah and I already found out
that I'm I found out I'm negative but I
have to do a swab to make double sure
and then I'll still keep my distance cuz
you never know you never know keep on
going keep on I don't know I just wish
we I wish people would get this sense
that there's such there's such a
division in this country where I mean
people really feel like they have to
join teams and I just wish people will
wake up and realize like whether you're
a trans super liberal Prius driving snow
flake from West Hollywood or you're a
farmer who
former vet you know former military
veteran from Ohio like we're on the same
team and if we don't realize that soon
and and kind of join together like this
French Revolution Third Estate where we
have to the proletariat has to really
understand that it doesn't matter what
our political beliefs are cuz we're
[ __ ]
yeah there's this this other team that's
coming down on us unfortunately I don't
think that's gonna happen til there's a
vaccination I don't know if they're ever
gonna get there but I think the
vaccination would make people feel more
therapy yeah where do you think it goes
from here though like what do you think
the rest of the summer looks like I've
heard I've heard two different things
I've heard people say yeah it's probably
gonna be like SARS remember with SARS is
just like a thing we adapted and it just
went away it could be that we know you
know hot weather kills it you know you
look at South East who's crushing it you
know so I also think way to bury like
the flu you know from state to state
yeah it's gonna vary greatly for some in
Vegas I mean over there it's
loosey-goosey already Vegas your fear
how do you like living in Vegas TV yeah
that's where people don't know where you
live yeah did she give to the government
baby people forget Nevada like they have
this notion of like Scorsese films in
Nevada and like you know like oh no then
that is [ __ ] old Cowboys yes like you
know Bill is like that very all kind of
stop the rumors dad yeah give me a
headache
but you you are you liking what do you
think what you take on Vegas you want to
share a thing about Vegas with the Vegas
Las Vegas with the strip clothes is just
painfully ordinary of a city desert well
yet without the strip without everything
when and when you just hold everybody's
hand in their own little towns
everything you're just in a [ __ ] town
that's a circle food yeah painfully
ordinary of a place where not to sushi
the other night and it was [ __ ] weird
went out to dinner we have a nerd it
felt stupid it felt like people are
masks
well yeah the waiters waitresses they're
all amassed the tables are apart it just
felt like why are we out doing this I'd
rather not go why am I using these
people's forks I don't know where this
was I do it was and I'm the last person
to be like that I'll say this it feels
dumb why don't we just bring this home
and eat this on the couch why are you
using a fork at sushi yeah that's a
better question
true Brian iron Houston next weekend
once you know we have restaurant
reservations and yeah I'm like yeah but
are you guys give me a mascot like no
dude regular [ __ ] it felt weird manager
and I'm the last person to say that I
was like this feels [ __ ] weird in
there just didn't feel right it wasn't
there was like a little in the air just
felt real tight everything was tight
people would walk in you just look at
the people and automatically [ __ ] what
do you think they're doing in
Penitentiary's I see the [ __ ] up thing
I never got sick in jail ever never
never even a [ __ ] cold
why nothing nobody gets sick I was in
jail for well what the thing is that's
what everybody's paying about in prison
is that it's things will spread but like
the place I was was so [ __ ] dirty I
swear to god a covert died when it got
bail up right it's like we all up
defense we were some that you saw that
prison in Tennessee 98% of the inmates
got it symptomatic yeah that's what it's
not telling you there is no release it
horrible criminals into society because
we keep them inside prison they let that
one go you got out two days later well
you see the video of the guys like
licking each other's water bottles are
like if I can possibly get out of here
from Kovac [ __ ] it I don't see it it's
crazy but you said in Fort Dix they had
it was always cold though right yeah I
was always cold freezing but I mean in
the cold her vet they say coke in the
summertime it was hot as [ __ ] like so it
was like living outside it's a mess
don't spread diseases yeah I think just
being around people I think when you're
in that it's literally the opposite of
being quarantine like when you're
quarantined you're caught you're not
around people your immune system there's
no way can get stronger when you just by
yourself yeah if your serac you're
living with 50 guys at a time all
different races ages you're gonna have a
strong not the best sanitation yeah you
know I'm going to take a piss and and
you pit you were like I shouldn't piss
in these toilets cuz it oh yeah well
yeah they try to like like that yeah
they've been locker the locker rooms you
know it's a lot of light to lock its
living in a locker room yeah locker room
attitude sky topia you
I took ya through coin buy my son yeah
my son look down at all of us that we're
at a parker to me because this looks
like a guy topia nope nope he went this
is guy topia my tattoo artist killed a
guy and so he's looking at doing some
time yeah there's a tattoo art since he
has a skill should be okay right
oh yeah yeah you got a he's gonna be in
there for little walk he's gonna do
enough time to like acquire the actual
stuff to build a tattoo gun and you
can't just you don't walk in there like
he go like there's somebody he's gonna
take over somebody else's hustle
basically because they already got a
tattoo guy in there so he's gonna be
taking business not like oh yeah he's
got it depends well who's good at you
know the only good at black and white
and drop he's gonna be fine
they should be are he'll be fine don't
you do too much time but yeah you think
he'll be fine in jail yeah he'll be fine
everybody's life even rat if you're not
a rat or a child molester you're fine
like there's no reason to be given what
cuz he's nice hair what about it but in
I think penitentiary breaks up into
different gangs
yeah but he's didn't he's define though
he's an artist he's an art yeah he'll be
fine it just sucks he killed his friend
right like that's just looks like what
are you gonna give him a hard time the
kids in socks you know it's like
everybody's humor at the end of the day
you're not gonna try to add to
somebody's pain like socks it's a really
good point you know I don't know like
that's another problem I think with like
this this kind of gotcha culture where
people are so hungry I don't know I feel
like they well yes I feel a little bit
you know it's weird though you just
maybe they put it on the back seat cuz
that guy we have real problems well
maybe I hope so Hansol culture cuz I
feel like a lot of that's so much
celebrities cuz they're giant [ __ ]
they've all been like the state
stay inside save a life and then they're
match and they see there I go
okay season two twilight seven whatever
but I feel like there's like a lot of
athletes and people have put [ __ ] out
where usually and comics that you might
in some trouble there maybe you've been
paying attention to it don't whatever do
there may be fatigue from it but in
general the idea that where people have
to really scrutinize people's mistakes
it's a bad place to put it because that
it's it's it goes against what we are as
human beings like we're all [ __ ]
imperfect and we all make really bad
mistakes especially when we're young and
this notion of like you're better I'm
better than you because of said mistake
it's it's and I think he'll be fine yeah
yeah are you going back then yeah yeah I
just mean I think it's so funny cuz if
you if you got caught I don't know doing
something sexually questionable know you
can be done forever yeah if you get
caught lying about something lying about
something you didn't and profiteering
off of other people's suffering as far
as business but I think he'll as a
tattoo artist when he comes out he'll be
yeah his talent yeah if he if if he got
out next week yeah cuz he didn't do
anything I feel actually socks dying he
[ __ ] up it's a shitty citrus for
everybody involved but he's not a bad
person and that's all that means he'd
took a left means she's taking a right
yeah that's one of those things he's
it's such a shame dude it's terrible but
yeah I think back like if all the [ __ ]
that I did that I thought I should have
really harmed other people yeah and I
was lucky enough not to it's just
impossible for me just like sit and
passed judgment because yeah I I drove
drunk and high every day for like four
years
like there was not a day that went by
where I was in inebriate like highly
inebriated and behind the wheel you're
good driver and uh you know I you know I
got the wrong thing I got duis and stuff
but I never I never crashed into you
know I never hurt anybody but like the
chances of that being the case are shown
below I'm so [ __ ] lucky and so I
think back it's like who can move my two
[ __ ] past exactly I feel that way
about everything I mean I agree with you
let me take we all [ __ ] up Mike and I
you still receive me word if I take a
sip from this no I don't know absolutely
have that
more doesn't look like a good bottle
doesn't say it's a problem yeah I'm the
problem people often ask me that Glade
they're like I'd love for you to come to
my bachelor party whatever are you gonna
have a problem with fill in the blank
and you know initially you know the
first like six months to a year yes
right it was probably rough to be around
it but now it's quite the opposite
there's there's zero kind of euphoric
recall to drinking using for me so I
don't sit and watch people enjoying
themselves and being happy and then get
this trigger what happens what hurts is
long stretches of time of boredom I've
found myself through but like watching
shows that I've Michael [ __ ] uh and
Leslie during the lockdown I'm like [ __ ]
a couple cold [ __ ] badillo's go down
real easy right now or or you know
anything that long rip will be really
sweet [ __ ] relax and didn't think
about so it's kind of these idle hands I
think that it's more anytime anytime I'm
like when I make the most usually the
most drastic crazy decisions when I'm
bored out of bored it's not out of like
any it's always like I'm like I'm in
Vegas I literally got so bored in Vegas
that's when I started doing porn mags
Nikko and his his girlfriend's Nicole it
came out of boredom I was in Las Vegas
just it was hot nothing in like just
literal boredom how it happened can you
say the genesis of yeah yeah he's do it
stand out I was doing stand-up yes he
used to be involved in understandable
Vegas it's good to stand up in Vegas is
weird too though wait Oh strange I'll
Taurus it's something about it its life
feels like fakes painful your experience
within your experience of people in the
underworld
yeah do you think what drives a lot of
career criminals is the money or the
juice absolutely it's the juice in the
system and it's literally the last thing
use of the money I mean it it money is
always a factor I mean in everything we
do there's money well because I've seen
a thing with this the
guy he actually went to prison for like
20 years right had a felony and he was
found not guilty after 20 years they got
him out but he can't get a job yeah
because he has this he's in prison for
20 years so no one's hires him so laughs
unemployment thing yeah so he has no
experience he gets back in the work
field and was like even present with 20
years he's a huge black guy in his
resume
so what's he know yeah drugs there's he
make this money really fast he knows
that what does he know what are you
gonna do that's the biggest problem
I do think I also think that the juice
is a bigger thing that a lot of people
realize I give you it gives you it gives
you an identity too right that's the
thing I was thinking about the other day
as I was driving my wife's Volvo with my
young child in the back in a car seat
going you know to drop her off it like a
virtual zoom for her you know
lock down class and I'm driving home and
I'm thinking to myself like I used as
much as I loved crack and meth and and
drinking I loved it but a big part of it
was like I felt like a legit bad boy
yeah there was the goosebumps I would
get when I would drive to North Pasadena
where I'm surrounded by [ __ ] literal
murderers and I'm gay and I'm like this
suburbanite little pretty boy [ __ ] yeah
my life would never go into there where
I got real [ __ ] heart pod like I'm
waiting and I'm like are the cops coming
and there's a [ __ ] gangbanger about
to drop me off crack rocks and I think
there was a there was a [ __ ]
excitement to it that I never never
never I was watching this quarantine I
was watching this cartel show and these
guys were in Venezuela which is a [ __ ]
show right but these chicks make you
look like the best you should go there
cheap anyways so these two cartel
members their mom was running for a
government spot and if they haven't so
they they were being investigated by the
feds and the feds had undercover agents
so they played what they were saying and
they go yeah we need to flip this cuz we
need 20 million to fund our mom's
campaign we need 20 million like you get
you 20 million and it shows them and
then the the
undercover feds go yeah so we're gonna
do it in Hades though or know what you
do in Fiji we're doing Fiji and they're
right but I'm gonna Fiji and like it's
just better for us there and they're
like guy we're gonna feed you well
because they don't have jurisdiction
then it's Whaley the game of Fiji
they're gonna arrest if I get him and it
shows these two young men good-looking
their moms in government they have money
and it shows them on the plane you know
on their iPhones be like what's up but
for sure act like you've been there
before
but I go what's up and they're popping
bottles a week my girl go what the [ __ ]
are they doing like they're fine and Joe
and my girl goes yeah but to them like
that's like they grew up in like that
cartel world needs something to them
like yeah it's like an honorable Jews
them and I'm like I bet it is fun like
while you're doing it yeah but it's a
[ __ ] rush well that's why compared to
like I mean I know you guys go I mean it
could be the same as like comparing like
stand-up like fighting like the rush you
got going like water yeah it's like the
endorphins the rush cuz a lot of people
get that from stand-up and I don't get
that from stand-up I like stand-up
because I think it's fun and you're not
gonna die doing yeah I don't know orphan
like my job that you were doing I just
use a little work yeah yeah cuz it's
like almost like when I see like like
Special Forces guys and stuff like talk
about how like they're badass for like
killing people like there's no
ramifications for like you're killing
people like legally you know what I mean
like I'm like I know key people that
yeah you know it's like it's they like
I'm like there's a different thing when
you have that risk of you really on the
edge and everything can be taken away
there's just nothing there's nothing
like it well the special force you guys
have a risk of a guy that is that is a
huge part of the job talk to those guys
it's a huge part of the juice Jason and
you in they they've proven that in
high-stress situations you develop deep
bonds you secrete oxytocin yeah that's a
deep deep connection with the people
you're with so then now you got real
friends brothers blood bring in depend
on that you can depend all made the walk
you've all been the fog why do you want
to be around a bunch of [ __ ] people
like actors when you come to holidays
I'm gonna give a [ __ ] about you you're
the show gets canceled they won't even
[ __ ] dip give you a [ __ ]
if you'd I'm [ __ ] one after seven
years you start you start these guys in
the business you [ __ ] give a pound of
your own flesh you go hungry for these
[ __ ] and when the chips are
down I'm [ __ ] I'm poor I got a piss
out of my huge dick you guys keep
calling no that's right I'm gonna throw
up cuz I'm sick yeah see how a glove
I'll trick you up Steve out I was
thinking about this too like obviously
El Chapo had some sort of work ethic and
he's a smart dude yeah Lucky Luciano
who's basically started the business of
the Italian mafia I wonder if you took
those guys put them in regular business
settings like Apple or you know you know
company Hulu whatever company Amazon and
what if they succeed at the regular
business to not judge I don't know cuz
you don't really have that risk there
it's like some it's you business man and
they also like Todd they make that [ __ ]
sound so much more complicated than it
is the drug stuff yeah like it's not I
mean it is but it's not like you know
what to be like Elon Musk you don't have
to be like [ __ ] if he's not gonna be
the reason you know yeah yeah I think
it's not like they have leadership
qualities in like its Lucky Luciano his
whole thing was we we don't he didn't
want to get into drugs he's like that's
what's gonna get us in trouble first
like if we get into drugs
gonna crackdown us we shouldn't give the
drugs and the time off it ended up
beginner drugs and that's one of the
reasons he got busted but his whole
thing was he what he did run a pretty
tight busy yeah like what if you take
that and pray that that leaders and
people who directed my work either
coughs you can't kill people but yank
that and put them in a regular business
setting would they still succeed I
wouldn't like like would Pablo Escobar
who's you know they say worth like four
billion dollars at his height he off see
he had some sort of logistics business
mariya guys didn't have kanopolis to get
me guys there are that start at a low
level and he built his obviously killing
time people but built his way up and
then figured things out right well for
the Connells
from X's and O's standpoint I think you
make a good point like obviously they're
capable but one wonders like if you
don't love what you're doing would you
be
willing to commit to doing it a meeting
like the same passion like I knew I knew
a lot of guys when I was in like the
punk rock hardcore world like I knew
these guys that were like especially in
like grindcore bands and death metal
bands where they knew going in they
weren't gonna get big listenership they
were working to sell a lot of records
they weren't to make a lot of money
shoddy but they were so [ __ ]
technically skilled at playing guitar
they were so worlds ahead of most people
and and I go like you're so good playing
it why don't you go me daily role and
they go I don't what I don't like it I
want to play that music it doesn't
excite me and I think they can sit there
and they can it spend 12 13 hours going
over these obscure scales because that's
what pumps them up but if you tell them
you know you could make a lot more money
you can have a lot more longevity being
a studio musician and they'd be like
well [ __ ] you I don't it doesn't it
doesn't get it going you know so
whenever there's like that similarity
it's like the same thing because that
way even if you want to Pablo Escobar I
can do instead of cocaine let's have you
push pharmaceutical drugs right yeah
it's legal but there's a big market dude
so let's put your brain behind that and
do that I want if you just flourish yeah
I just think about all the logistics
have to go through now especially with
the feds and you know with the with the
wall and you know all those stuff
because what drug cartel members dude
you maybe you know better than me Stevie
but they want the least resistance the
path path of least resistance like water
right yeah wherever the waters gonna go
where it gets the least resistance so
they're doing submarines they're going
from Venezuela you know figured they had
all these little boats all the company
tons of boats that would get only so far
they'd have to rege ass and keep going
but we took that away
so then what they do they got high-end
high-end jet like jets that billionaires
use cuz and weird land and no one to
assume that it was loaded with drug
because like why would this building I'd
be doing drugs but they just played the
part of billing it mmm they'd have
someone rent these huge sure jazz a
world that way so the director can't see
coming up with stuff yeah you're always
working on it but you know they've done
Studies on criminals on psychological
profiles on criminals
and they usually have the same
psychological makeup as a racecar driver
or someone who can take risks hi Rizzoli
and and well or special forces getting
guys who know guys who tell guys they're
all tiny little guy but body yeah it's a
personality type though where you don't
get nervous the way most people do you
have a tracker
you know they don fight science or
sports science they did they studied
like high clutch players right guys who
just were amazing athletes when all the
chips were down their heart rate didn't
really go up they just stayed so calm so
there's a personality trait I feel like
goes with people that take huge risks
whether it's be on must has that or Jeff
Bezos has that may mean Steve Jobs yeah
I'm a big I'm a big I'm a big Elon fan
but I think what goes on with Elon and
Savior no no I'm not this is not in any
way spades my big fan but I think what
goes on with him is that you have a man
with a almost preposterous science
fiction IQ that is also bactrim yeah
there's air I so is he on the spectrum
or we just all so stupid
he's a different free talk to regular
people as like talking to food visionary
he's a visionary so as he goes very big
as a visionary he's got he's got you
know the idea I think he makes a billion
dollars what what I'm saying is I and
I'm certainly not qualified to make that
kind of claim like he's on the spectrum
addition that but I do know that there
he's different than us in the sense that
um I used to after my divorce I I was I
had this hard time even like getting
back into the world I was like the only
thing I was going good for me was was
work so I just [ __ ] said I'm gonna
commit myself to radio I'm gonna my
whole life's gonna be radio I'm gonna
worry about shake something about and
then after like a year I had this female
friend like I'd never thought in a
million years I would develop a friend
that I wouldn't [ __ ] that was female
like it's the only point for me in my
mind like that's the only reason you
hang out girls I'm still that was and
she graduated from UCLA early and went
to MIT studying this very exotic form of
physics and this
you know really really really really
smart smarter brainy I'm Becky but she
also was very attractive and one things
just kind of fell into place in one
night we ended up doing oh yeah and I
would so I was like we're gonna make
this work we're actually friends I like
her she gets along together was it hot
body doubles usuals real brainy girl
says no I don't want important questions
I don't want to get you into range issue
because I don't want it people will know
I'm science but she was a physically
collegiate swimmer so like she'll grab
some chocolate was a really attractive
athletic girl but she also happen to be
like 170 IQ and the problem was is like
I said I'm gonna make this relationship
no matter what you're going to hang out
we go and we hang out one day we go like
on a like first like kind of date day
who were you know every and I realize
like she is very frustrated talking to
me yeah compared to her yeah and and I
would even I was even insecure because
I'm like oh my gosh she thinks I'm such
a dummy and she's looking at me going
okay and then she you know wasn't big
you know when she wants you know he
lands on Jerry yeah where there's that
weird where he goes white any because
he's like she's sitting there at toast
on 3rd in the you know in West LA doing
the same [ __ ] thing to me and I and
we just drifted apart in others because
and so my point being is that like I
think when you when your brain works in
such a unique way it's almost a gravid
inability to kind of relate to the brain
that don't work in a unique way you know
that's true but I think that that dope
those you know those people are those
one percenters whether it's in whether
they're engineers or the athletes those
1% athletes those one per on must Jeff
Bezos Bill Bill Gates Steve Steven jobs
they have a tough time relaying to
anybody and getting a good group of
friends
yeah they don't appear yes you know
though yes and no though because a lot
of times what I've also found is very
very
our people are very smart in specific
ways but intelligence compartmentalized
so a lot of times you bring something to
the table which is humor to them which
is a total mystery give another one of
you yeah or or just or learn after every
on Ricky Morty though when you get them
laughing or when you get them to see
another part of the world they're you're
you're in like this exact conversation
with Tony Jefferies he goes this is
years ago yes dude have this big meeting
with all these bigwigs and these tell me
there's these tech guys I said Tony
don't forget you you bring something to
the table that they don't man they don't
have the perspective that you had since
you were five yeah your goal was to be
on the national team of in England and
you accomplish that so while they put
their bathes in their heads and books
and became engineers you bared your head
in fighting it's no different dude you
could have been them he may be a little
stupid but you could have been if you
buried your head in books you could be
the it's you'd went this way they went
this way doesn't mean you're less smart
they might know more about engineering
or business than it's what you love this
do yeah and you bring that which they
don't bring so don't don't go in there
with a negative at you think oh these
guys so much smarter than well I think
there are a lot of that deal and his
businesses but that's not the point but
I think a lot of that just really to do
with you in stand-up is that you
probably I'm speculating but you
probably initially dealt with that when
you're making the transition where it's
like I'm I'm this fighter cage fighter
meathead these guys are all these you
know comedian type you know like I
wouldn't even say Brian's is very
similar to like the the the average
commedia especially in Los Angeles it's
the nebbishy kind of hipstery guy mark
you know and in Beck here comes this
buff handsome [ __ ] six foot four guy
but but then there's that moment where
you realize you're like oh I'm bringing
something else to the game that they're
not yeah I have an athlete's work at
another athletes that's really because
of yeah you know so there-there is
that's true in a lot of regards I'm some
of the best radio people are not these
studied broadcasters they're like
they're like like adverts a lot of a lot
of like a former cops former military
look at Corolla Corolla is in my opinion
in the top 10 greatest of all time
and Corolla got on radio because he was
Jimmy Kimmel's boxing trainer for a
celebrity button if it wasn't for that
weird [ __ ] hitch happen chance
meeting when we're not well Jimmy was
Jimmy Campbell was the sports Kevin and
bean about 20 years ago he was that was
I don't know Jimmy was a radio guy and
he got in a in a on-air fight with
another staff member at K rock and so
they're like fine
let's it we're gonna settle this in the
ring and we're gonna get we're gonna
sell tickets because it'll be great so
Kimmel goes out and gets a trainer this
other guy goes out and gets a trainer
Kimball gets Corolla who happened to be
listening and he says I'm gonna drive
down to Kay rock and I'm gonna offer my
services up starts training Kimmel for
this thing and then after a while Jimmy
comes back on the air he's like you guys
my boxing trainers one of the way to get
him on the air I had analyzed they
started doing these characters on Kevin
and bean and next thing you know he goes
the love line and boom and that's so
funny because it's clear yes Adam
brought something that the the 95% of
guys in talk radio are either political
due to our stuffy or form of frat guys
that are like I'm the wild and crazy
morning guy or they're mimicking people
that they know us so there's it's all it
all kind of sounds the same and and and
Corolla brings this incredibly new
blue-collar regular guy you know ethic
on top of his ridiculous acerbic wit but
he brought something different amazing
my point is I didn't know that yeah we
have them on the show Monday he's all my
job people Monday oh he canceled daddy's
gotta be in with his dad and the problem
with this with Adam is it because I need
this money and the problem is Adam works
in Pasadena or Glendale for Kay every
day so we have to go bro halftime we're
we're gonna for I'm working on it right
now a big car guy I'm working on oh yeah
get a minute oh yeah he's awesome
you best yeah I had no idea to tell you
got to start he's always been if you
emerge even came off the man show I know
you guys started but on the man show he
was kind of like this side piece there
right but he was he was so funny you
like who's that guys like everything
he's all I got where
kids like that he was like a real Idol
to me you know not to sound too
cheeseball but a because he literally
came from the same place I did so like
there's always that in the back of my
mind like Jimmy was on the same radio
show I was some maybe someday I could be
a big star - there's that kind of
daydreaming a special but on top of that
like whether he was the sports guy at
Kevin and bean making $25,000 a year or
he's now the late-night host on ABC
hosting the [ __ ] Oscars he hasn't
changed he is awesome talk to anyone who
knows - Kimmel on any level the nicest
most considerate dude he's always
hooking people with jobs trying to take
care of people looking to build a
network he is he loves it he loves to
throw parties at Corolla told me he's
like they were on the man showed they
said they weren't like they weren't
balling yet but they were their careers
are building and Adam says hey you know
I ran I don't know if we should do
Christmas gifts this year it's like we
both you know we're grown adults why do
we do and gimel said no no it's
Christmastime were [ __ ] buying gifts
and it wasn't because he wanted to
receive him Jimmy loved giving him and I
was like yeah you're not taking that
away from me you know he's a he's a
great they're both so ty don't know him
but he's loved I love him you know it's
weird is I bet I've done the Adam show a
million times I think we've had him on
here he's never once talking about
fighting really not what's pretty cool
the first time I did this show he
brought up Rhonda I think - please don't
do that
his guy get it and never did it again
yeah yeah it if you did bring it up with
him it you'd be shocked to know hey how
did it know cuz Brian was like you know
he did some boxes ago here we go
I don't entertain watch him he he admits
with James Tony and like Adam can box
Anakin seriously box I mean not look
again is he gonna step in the ring
tomorrow against Errol you know like is
he gonna get in against lemon chanko of
course not but he could eat him Reed he
really knows what he's doing he's not a
big strong kid there but people also
don't know my power so he actually
competes in driving like yeah he's a
hyper drive I didn't know driver driver
and that's what would be the most
expensive hobby it's the most hobby huh
oh dude millions and millions dollars
going those cars really yeah I remember
when I drove I had a I had a 66 GTO and
I loved it it wasn't show quality but it
was close it was a beautiful
and I vested a lot of money and time and
effort into it and I'm a big muscle car
guy I understand like the the Porsche
workers I love it but I'm an American
muscle car guy
I got into I get it they're ridiculously
they're good just in a straightaway
you're responsible like it was before
anyone like who do you know our age it's
like balls deep and muscle cars you know
it's like an eye thing my brother knows
them which I'm like Angela anybody I
know they just live like up a New
Hampshire I think Klopp Klopp has a 64
GTO that's what we use a beater we
should drive around town and Orson ality
thing I think it's a personality thing I
appreciate it yeah jog over Americana
I'm a classic I'm silly oh I'm like a in
the same ballpark as like a Tarantino I
love old American television I love
american-made I do to go see how I do
that too but I never I I always kind of
like vitalize the idea of like American
rebellion and the idea of a eight mile
to the gallon 496 was a way for you just
drive like this out you know I can't
turn no powers it's it's it's prepared
wonder what is it's very representative
of I think of America this is this
outlaw idea it's a it's insane that
you're like makes no sense
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] GM yeah a Ford made the
made the Mustang yeah we got to go
bigger got to go heavier faster bigger
cubic engine okay [ __ ]
Pontiacs like oh yeah hold my beer yeah
you know and this is like the 862 the
mid seventies there's this insane idea
that we're just gonna build more [ __ ]
function yes [ __ ] function digger these
stock cars that came out then oh yeah oh
yeah
they were the Camaro the the car he's
the GTO of the you know the the Firebird
the the Mustangs the Cobras the bosses
so you would go to learn by him how many
then you start getting monsters then you
start going crazy when you talk about
like like you know the bumblebees and
the and that Cudas and stuff where they
just said we're
yeah [ __ ] you guys Iman monies of that
era here's what's cool Mike that that is
back yeah no one's really noticing but
Ford dodge Dodge especially with the
Hellcat it's like hold on I can go to
the dealer I'm an 18 year old let's say
my dad has money I can go to the dealer
and get a help adding up a hellcat or
the deal with a thousand vibrator you
can do that now
oh yeah the Hellcat has a switch where
it's like 600 horsepower is good enough
for today but here let this one get the
900 horsepower if I really want to lose
yes
so that's 700 horsepower srt hellcat how
much does that they're like eighty a
less than a hundred but it they're
monsters on straightaway track a [ __ ]
you know III like I said I appreciate
I'm a car guy I appreciate your aiming
your Porsche I'd look at em on my
machine I have this this this young kid
a phenomenal story I forget the name of
it oh when it's finished off bumps
highlight it but this young kid who he's
on the the Speed Channel and he's worked
with Top Gear and I see him at I see
Matt ten-speed coffee it's a bike shop
coffee shop and I was hanging out there
and he starts talking about my car girl
what do you do what do you do and he
goes ah I customize cars and stuff like
that and then probably like three weeks
later he goes hey I'm actually I work
with bodenhouse and we make a custom
exhaust in tune and our project we want
to do is this gt2 RS are you interested
I know do my cars perfect I want to [ __ ]
with it it's perfect mark here's I get
it week goes by us dude let me just say
you some pictures what we can do so he's
sitting these pictures and I started get
to know him well his his mom and his dad
both got cancer passed away left them
he's 25 years old so they left him he's
on his own note has nobody so he goes I
get emotional topic he goes the last
thing my mom told me was to live my
dreams he is so I'm starting my my
business around cars and we want to work
on your car I said you could have my car
dude I know you're gonna do it yeah I'll
pay for you for your service lawless you
can highlight my car he goes because we
it for the Speed Channel and Top Gear
and we want to feature a car by need gt2
RS ah you can do by car dude I believe
in you
he was really I believe in you drop my
car off on Wednesday and his new shop
it's the first car they're gonna do he's
doing he's doing a custom tune he's
doing this custom exhaust that he built
he's the artistic guy and so he looked
at the way bone house is doing exhaust
him he goes the he's so detailed the
first minute talking about this kid's
detailed he goes the way Bowden does it
they have these extra passageways which
is it's not as efficient I want to take
that and I want explains optimator you
can do it dude you can do it here's my
car jeez and he gets emotionally as I
can do it you can do it dude now he also
he's the the head designer and rep for
Toyo tires which worked with the UFC huh
he has all these connections and he goes
the the it's so hard for me in the car
space cuz everyone's older heads yes
these guys but me out yeah I said nah
[ __ ] that especially in the European
sports car yeah yeah that's amazed that
beautiful man I love it yeah I mean it's
a crazy story and then I go to shop in
North Hollywood and he's like you know
it's such a got so much he shows me the
shop and it's ridiculous man it's him
and three three of his friends well they
got election in the complete opposite
direction let me finish my story about
my GTO sorry so I'm going to do crawl
the show one day at his compound in
Glendale and my store sorry but it's in
my story so let me get his name right
it's in my story ya know make sure to
give the guys name is Daniel but I want
to make sure to get his hit the business
right so I I know crawls like a car guy
and I have my GTO and this is probably
like 2012 and I 64 66
it was the first year that the that
Pontiac decided to make the GTO it's
actually own car instead of a special
edition and so I I got my 60 and I've
really gotten to the point where I'm
ready to show it off and I know I'm
going to do Kroll show so I Drive to
Corollas compound and I'm so excited I'm
like can't wait to show off my car to
card guy and I come and I pull in a
park-like revenant I'm like trying not
everything and Adam comes out he's like
I gotta run
ah he's a beautiful car and everything
and I'm like huh okay walk inside and
there's not not one not two eight
collection is a warehouse a vintage well
that's like I was literally like gonna
show show me a video of doing an arm bar
tour like Hickson Gracie you know it was
his showroom is so [ __ ] impressive
it's not just a car guy thing finally
this is a man who's going to compete in
a vintage race guy damn garage it's
really really impressive
he bought a bunch of Paul Newman's old
cars he's got some money yeah right yeah
yeah well you bought Paul Newman yeah I
mean it's a 4.4 million dollar Porsche
good times yeah you could have bought
out of your show win III buy horses for
someone else no yeah no it's gonna be
good it's daddy's gotta figure some
things out but hey no it's listen it's
it's off why are we in the car the years
you still in the cars I am yeah
I love him I was glad now I Drive this
er I had a UH
cts-v cadillac which I love I love but I
am it was like I'm up dad now and I
that's a cool dad car though it's a very
cool car but it's really small it's a
two-door I mean the baby seat when I put
it in the CTSV my daughter even when she
was an infant was like [ __ ] like
hitting up against the majesty so I sold
it and I got uh I got the the Grand
Cherokee but the SRT and I like Annette
you just it tickles me somehow where I'm
like this is [ __ ] insane I have a
Hemi in a Cherokee it's a Grand Cherokee
it's both of their like duty cruising
command car here I 596 horsepower it
drives like a sports car it's so
preposterous it's already bumpy
I think no Europeans like I think for me
with the amazing amazing I think was the
gp2 RS I get such an outlandish car
rides for racetracks when the fast cars
on the Autobahn of all time set the
record beat of the Lamborghini I think
when I get in that car I'm like I'm
doing something right I think it just
reminds me I get it and when I dream
like I'm doing something right maybe
that's it I'm done I've been trying to
figure out for the longest time I can't
afford my tests many more but I know
it's gonna be fine if we all get this
for you get them Prius daddy please
I bought a Prius turns out I can't lend
that Prius to anybody Brennan because
well um I will get sued if somebody
crashed it cuz the insurance and they'll
find out so I have a piece of metal and
I found out that the toyota dealership
up sold me on warranty stuff so I didn't
realize that alone they snuck in $7,000
extra in warranty see Santa Monica
Toyota [ __ ] me
they they they would you sold out all
this so I bought a $17,000 car but no i
didn't i bought it $24,000 car they
tacked on all that stuff which i didn't
know i didn't like on that cuz 130 bucks
a month older car santa monica and i
told him i was helping out somebody who
is who in law in our country said I'm
helping somebody out I don't want to
know that I'm getting it but he's a
veteran I want to buy him a car I want
to let him borrow a car they were like
we got you dog we got you and they
[ __ ]
they said let's tack on an extra seven
grand so you [ __ ] me for seven grand
good job you got me I can handle it not
anymore but I can and the point is that
that's what you did so I'm gonna go to
Santa Monica Toyota and I'm gonna talk
to them about this chain go to secret
studios but it's spelled s EK rit
studios pronounced secrets news but it's
s EK rit s yawns oh what's saya
yet this kid man I'm telling you dude
secret studios does that make Lehren
there they're doing my car they're doing
t3 but yeah that's them in North
Hollywood there that is [ __ ] that slappy
ones that gt3 but yeah there did you
know these young hustlers and they're
they're making moves man yep and I was
like you know young me give you a chance
let's let's [ __ ] do it man authority
oh yeah that's a gt3 yeah they're so I
mean like I think you know chef-inspired
it's only a shot man it's not explained
being a car guy to people who are not
car people you know I I don't know why
it's just something I'd love I did I
just don't always love it I think
there's a lot of it is a growing up in
LA where driving is not it's not
optional I think the car culture New
York car culture is a big thing here you
know growing up is every teenage boy at
least it used to be the way every
teenage boy dreams of driving in the
freedom that comes along with it but in
Southern California it's like it's a
whole different thing you know car
culture is a big deal I think it's just
you you are the love cars you don't yeah
I can look at any car and it does
nothing for him it doesn't make sense
I look at a working-class German
Shepherd and I get excited like we all
have different weird ideas of what we
like oh I'll see I'm saying whether you
send me I'll see a senior Porsche and it
will almost bring me to tears and I was
in Malibu at the Malibu Saturday and
this where Seinfeld was there and his
boy spike and they had their 911 ours
and I was like holy [ __ ]
Thunder see no 911 are before what is
that show me that it is the show rare
and you have to get allocated one you
have to own previous Porsches to get it
and I'm looking at those and then this
this singer in they call it the Malibu
singer and I've heard of it it's like
it's like Bigfoot it pulls up
I enjoy [ __ ] what's wrong with you I
got choked up why it was type in Malibu
singer that's a that's a 911 our 911 our
it looks the same pregnant but if
they're not it's stick shift but then I
Porsche went oh these are impossible to
get and everyone wants this we're in
released the corn the touring gt3 that's
the malibu singer oh you know get the
inside look at know that will give you
up you know are look at the inside pods
beautiful work of art you just not I get
that way with an ass this year
see and I'd go I'm gonna cry you don't
drink girls in cars are the only thing
that do that I'm not talking around like
oh yeah of course
but that dad that's see to me I would
just look at that and go that so where
now is that a very expensive car that's
Bigfoot one for 1.7 million and you saw
that pull up pull up and they asked me
if I was interested in buying it and
what your is it well would it so singer
will take these old Porsches that reason
the seventies and then they they will
make on their own where they're you know
and from the stitching on the seat that
you see you pick out so it's a two-year
process and you pick out everything from
the engine to the stitching to the color
of the the the dials to the steering
wheel to the rearview mirror to it
everything to so I'm gonna that'd be a
dream for me it's like if a if I see
here know would be a rista mod of like
I'd make a daily driver out of like a 70
El Camino or a 69 the the singers a 1
million dollar car so million dogs but
you can get singers for like probably
six hundred grand from if you go there
it's a it's a two-year weightless so see
that see that exhaust see how they cut
out the the mesh in the back that it's
me like that but even more so so you
know the stock GTR s2 comes with 700
horsepower and when they do all this you
get right around nine hundred it's all
about what you need I don't know what to
look for you know what to look for right
I had a guy who is a cab driver show me
the difference he said between opera
singers that sounds weird but they were
too famous Pavarotti and another Plus do
they make over and he was explaining
showed me goes now and he told me what
to listen for and once I learned what to
listen for
you can't go back once you see the
difference you go oh [ __ ] I see I see
what you're saying but it's like it was
in everything even even when shoes like
be like wait what do you like those
Reagan's they look like normal dunks
like I'll you don't understand 2004
these were such a big deal fine you know
the back story we find the original ray
guns yeah the supreme dunks came out it
was this little little skate shop in New
York then a collab with Nike yeah it
changed the industry it's like a but
it's that shoe that started the fad well
you know it's weird I don't like how
i I material things are truly not
important to your quality of life agree
i I really think I want a handsome
before I say this yes but at the same
time driven a thing there there is there
is something weird happening now where
you're supposed to be ashamed of success
yes in a way that I don't like and I and
I really like what I really love is Mike
my Armenian friends because they don't
[ __ ] my grandpa move away from Armenia
come here to church kill his family
I drive Mercedes [ __ ] you [ __ ] you ball
chains
I love that it's like no you're right
yeah you know what you [ __ ] your
family work for your ass off to develop
wealth be proud of it that unity their
entrepreneurial and I subscribe to that
because you know when I post my cars or
bike or something like that
the older heads you wrote you got your
daliyah's a little bit with me but
though my peers my the older guys who
are my best friends rogon would say
never post your car
never ever post anything that don't let
people know how well you're doing but I
subscribed a different younger
generation where they came there seeing
it they came with me on the journey
where I was this fighter where I can
afford anything and but I started a
podcast and they came with me on the
right so when I post stuff of that they
you're oh [ __ ] yeah dude because they
know what went in be great no absolutely
absolutely that's almost like hey check
it out we did it I agree cool it's to
write both sides oh I agree has a you
know in a country where there's there's
plenty there's obviously a division in
income and and you know employer it can
be insulting to people I understand that
totally but what I don't understand is
how that can be translated into you
should be bashful or ashamed of the fact
that you're the reason for why I was I
did a TV show for a long time a pilot
did get picked up but they flew me to UM
we've filmed it in Belfast it was [ __ ]
to me officer freed north her trip to
Belfast was great so we film it there
and the the network blew me first class
you know and I'm not about I'll be
honest I will not fly first class unless
someone else paid for it but I was like
this
like wow well you know they live they
seat you first
right in first class feel ashamed and as
as the first people started to come on
the plane behind me I wasn't I was
seriously like oh no I feel horrible for
her and I thought to myself as I was
playing you know that it's a long flight
halfway through I was like wait a second
would Don Draper have been ashamed of
sitting in first class you know would
where did that go where I I assumed in
1965 a man in business suits sitting in
first class a guy comes down the aisle
with his child and he goes someday you
work hard you could be like him yeah
whereas now it's like I know let me hit
my kid and go you know that's weird but
but I think it's a society issue where
like that should be inspiring like when
I see Kevin Hart post something where
the rock bossom or
you know anybody anybody Tom Segura your
catcher when I see it it's like that's
possible just okay like like every
podcaster should find what Rogen did
where he made way more money in the
reporting that should be so
inspirational for everyone no one should
always a sell it that it makes sense you
should find that so inspirational that
your holy [ __ ] that's possible in
podcasting right yes and people for the
past five years have been making [ __ ]
Bank podcasting me and Brian are two
[ __ ] morons and we make up goodham
doing this and without you you guys to
to our best friends we can pay for this
it's crazy
yeah because we decide to do the show
that should be inspiring to everyone who
watches it but me and I are the smartest
guys in the room by far man I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] with CTE but people should
find that stuff inspiring right
it's a I don't see when they post this
now is founded on that idea of potential
like you may not be a millionaire today
but you will be tomorrow which is
stopped revolution from happening in
this country yes as long as we protect
that American dream as long as we
protect the idea that if you use your
ideas and if you are innovative and if
you take risk that's a huge part you
take the risk preach if you take the
risk and you have the [ __ ] effort and
you're willing to fail a lot you can
make it yeah it's kind of like a know
you that's when you can get to be 53 and
okay right now we're at a low point but
I love what we're gonna get back up a
challenge anyone me and Brian over there
about three times a week go by SpaceX
and and not find that inspiring right
with the rocket ship and all this stuff
and it's it's in the hood yeah and you
know what he did with just his lot of
land the buildings the parking the
greenery the ficuses the spaceship drive
over there yeah Elon Musk you know
there's a ton of astronomical engineers
where the [ __ ] he is there's a ton of
those guys but he took risk man it's
about me he went you know what this is
an issue I'm gonna try to sell taking
risk yeah people don't realize that when
you look at a business somebody started
a business and they got really
successful and people you hear a lot of
the stuff like what the workers share in
the profits and they should get just as
much the worker didn't take the risk
guys when you create a company from an
idea when you come up with an idea and
you build a company around it the amount
of energy that goes into that the amount
of fires you have to put out every
single day and finally they did the
financial but mainly the risk I actually
don't know anybody who's made a lot of
money who wasn't poor at one point who
didn't who didn't lose it all at one
point so you know you're always riding
that balance you're always taking that
risk and people that are willing to
change and and go with the flow and
adapt adapt you've got to learn how to
change your [ __ ] approach a lot but
also say this is it's also I would I
would assume with Elon Musk's with
anyone who's made any sort amount of
money they didn't do it because they
thought that I don't think Elon Musk
decided to make Tesla or you know that
weird underground thing which we that
you know it's called subways let's put
cars in it that's fine subway but I
don't think he's he started any that we
didn't start the podcast or Rogen and
start the podcast and goes oh I'm gonna
make this maddham maddham this millions
in the future no one no one started
because of that right one and no one who
any of the aforementioned people
especially you were doing something
really different none of them
I'm sure a lot of us in this room
included had anybody going great idea go
for it never know I guarantee you there
was a bunch of comic friends of Joe
Rogan's that were going what are you
wasting your time on they go do TV Isaac
no III was there Brian how many your
friends made funny for doing the podcast
with me Oh Mike how many your friends
over because you were doing pocket and
the best part it'll come what are you
doing buddy I go dude I'm telling so
many of my friends all my friends all my
friends life what are you doing this all
Zack my buddies with this ghost me we're
not making any money you guys are
talking about dumb [ __ ] they take me to
the side Mike what are you doing this
with Brian this is a wasted one of my
friend said your two eleven year olds in
a tree house what are you doing dude you
should be acting you should be on TV I
guarantee I guarantee you go down the
list
Elon Musk a game of Thrones The Walking
Dead any genre of any type of business
where people are innovators they had a
litany of people going yeah I mean we
like the idea but um could you tweak it
this way it maybe do a little less
cussing not not too much by the end and
it's like no this is my vision I'm gonna
stick to it and after 10 15 20 years of
getting hearing no no no they finally
make it and all those people are like
great idea we've been pretty much it
even supporting that way the whole time
you know there's a I like the the number
one idea that comes into my mind is like
how many people told Matthew whiner I
think his name is the guy behind Matt
the creator of Mad Men yeah I mean a
legendary collection of nose nose nose
will get the production started and
finally they pull the plug all these
different networks all these different
people all they did wanted to change
change change and finally he's like no
I'm gonna stigma and in this obscure AMC
which nobody watched at the time decides
to take a chance on it and then of
course once it hits big every [ __ ]
every network's doing the 1960s Madison
Avenue [ __ ] New York City skinny tie
show so we've we've known all along this
is the way to go it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
but it makes you laugh I mean I love the
stories you guys always tell about the
Fox execs or it's like this is what you
need to do to be successful in a podcast
because now going back belt in broadcast
also got fired by the way yeah
most of work for a disown which is also
good and not like that but a lot of
people say no it's given they were like
you know you got a you got a sign with
the screw because they'll own 50% of it
but they'll get you and Brennan was like
no yeah which is better ourselves we'll
just figure it out so so much of that is
just being really that's the lone story
you know the Stallone rocky story yes
it's really an amazing almost unreal
beautiful story that idea that he had so
much money thrown his way this
relatively unknown guy and they're like
we'll buy the story we'll make the move
you'll get a production credit we're
gonna cast someone else though he's like
no no I'm Rocky yeah I'm Rocky then
that's a mindset that's followed by
LeBron James to it I think latter
yesterday was the anniversary signing
with Nike before he signed with Nike
when he was a senior in high school
coming out
Reebok went up to him that the guy who
owns Reebok goes here's ten million
dollars but don't talk to you other shoe
company in a year we're gonna we're
gonna sign a deal and he had his mom in
him nothing there no I'm not gonna do
that Reebok and I'm not get ten million
which would change his life because I'm
not gonna do that
the reports are I signed a
billion-dollar deal with Nike I could
use like bills that really yeah it's a
listen first time you don't be fine
Spotify if you want to buy this let me
just say I know let's be subtle Spotify
give us enough give me a call
I'm saying you got a man right here who
could maybe help you out a little bit I
don't know many 53 year olds in good of
shape as you with any kind of [ __ ]
thick [ __ ] you got this I like where
your head I'm thinking a little only old
man rinks oh man I'd never stop watching
Bryan Callen porn thank you oh we're
talking positive flyways
like look bread if Brenda makes fun of
my hair but I think looks good nice
frames my face nothing's fine in the kid
lines Stevie was it weird the first time
we're doing porno knowing you was gonna
get broadcasted oh well because I saw
the first one yeah you say you saw the
yeah five minutes give us give us the
give us the yeah it was because I knew
Nicole Nicole I had known her for a
couple years
just friends that we never even hooked
up and then it literally came out too
like I had I had I had to go to I had to
kind of hide in Vegas for a little bit
wait for some things to die down not
sketchy at all yeah that's my life I
should thank you so I'm literally bored
and it's just so the the world's
everything kind of aligned where she was
up with all the major studios all her
contracts to shoot stuff she reaches she
was a free agent she wanted to just do
exclusive stuff at her house with one
other person she had nobody to do it
with at this time and we're just it was
literally like we had hooked up once
before and then it was like do you want
it was like drop though that's like
Michael Jordan Tasha Baldwin let you
know I'm kind of a professional my size
a little bit Steve's got a dij but it
wasn't I would have been because I knew
her you know you can't look it up online
I got but I also like it was cuz I knew
her if I had if she was just this girl I
was jerking off to what she was because
I started the eMeter couples how I met
her slid into DMS and just kept it going
cuz I'll wait things I'm like a tiger in
the tall grass yeah I will wait this out
nothing too fast no I really was but now
there's like little trick she'll do when
it's weird if you like cuz we have like
a little screen setup and stuff on the
phone you can see it's okay
it's almost a mental thing if I feel
like I'm gonna bust I'll look at the
screen and it just like takes me out of
the whole situation so it's on that
screen just much it's just a video it's
like the monitor oh okay I'll look at it
and all of a sudden Ashwini like just
like it just desensitize you right but I
can like read or two dead dogs thank you
the rover - yeah now it's like anything
else you do it enough now we're like a
little camera crew like you wear a body
cam yeah I got a body cam on my stress
then like where the object no you got a
shoot today so this is what this just
happened this week I went to I'll go to
our house for a couple days we'll shoot
stuff we didn't shoot anything we just
hooked up not even loads we hooked up
for two days and we're like [ __ ] we
didn't film anything did we and I was
like well I gotta go to LA and she's
like I will get it next time
explain how you may have she makes money
it's all private yeah it's all in home
and so it's the only fan so now actually
I supposed to talk about this we just
signed an exclusive deal with brazzers
so we're gonna be doing stuff for Brad
you and her yeah me and her on the
browsers my big fan keep on what what
what tell with the exclusive deal yeah
browsers
what does always gets more money she
yeah how's that work she breaks me oh
she takes care of me yeah what your girl
a pole yeah she makes let's say you
weren't a couple with you weren't hey
there dude are you like in Brian's boat
dudes make I mean I do it I mean guys
don't make [ __ ] that's if it's not your
girl and like you guys don't have a
business thing to get your thing like
don't you couldn't you do like an
identifiable thing where people like you
I need to watch that time guys know what
I'm obviously watching for the girls I
like but I used to every once a while go
to the search bar at pornhub and go to
Nick Manning just cuz I'd hear
ah dropping [ __ ] loads get this thing
you know he's a dropping I got a [ __ ]
giant Homer Simpson tattoo on my thigh
yeah so when all these things all you
see is my [ __ ] and [ __ ] Homer Simpson
huge everybody blow you go yo yeah but
dude man it's just wait let me ask you
this so uh [ __ ] Nick man but let me
ask you so old so [ __ ] but she's got a
subscription only so she makes money on
her fans and now you're signing now
you're gonna go you have a very large
penis he's got a Houston that's a big
thing I have to show them the Homer
that's a beautiful take that for your
girls what happened you took that for
your girl all right that song of
somewhere in the internet you can fit
three of my dick on his dick look he's
got a dip you know but like so I mean
Brian are doing it but the thing is
that's it's good for sure it's a no
doubt it's professional quality but well
since well she hooked up with other guys
it's not to you it's just been me if she
hasn't shot with anybody else besides me
since last July she her previous work
yeah it's cuz she left me companies
she's brought some girls in for you yeah
that mean there's girl I mean there's
we're gonna do stuff in the future move
you like guys come in I don't know Ryan
needs a job now so it's probably gonna
we're friends like you like your shoes
like a what's the name Nick Manning I
don't know man it's gonna come over
today to it would have like the right
time I don't know it was just be one of
those surprise all right what are we
doing
yeah you get your cut yeah what if I
evil of you is coming over and you get
to my I would be great but it wouldn't
be like but then you get lost money
just say yeah anything now is your face
in it though because I saw one you said
Mia you were playing the guitar and yes
like Santa Claus and she was she was
giving you that wasn't that popular one
yeah cuz I'm you you don't realize that
the dude isn't like the star and the
thing like you really it doesn't I
the only mine who's that that's evil uh
via she's my favorite right now yeah I
like the the Asian mix you know a little
freckles I just want like that actress
that isn't in the new blump House movie
oh my god I've never seen a new blumpkin
thank you Mike
yeah no is yeah there's a new horror
movies like oh type in Fantasy Island
looks just like that Oh Maggie Q yes Oh
Maggie juice in impressions like her in
person Maggie Q is one of the one of the
hottest actresses I've ever met
[ __ ] she obviously she's beautiful he
does she look like we don't meet her she
she's radiant she's so [ __ ] hot
she's so yeah she looks like she's
Maggie goo call very good call
now I was evil evil ed to him my wife
looks like Danny Daniels the porn star I
talk to a lot of ways any place which
are like Amy Hendrix I'm this da and I
believe okay I'll do but mushy she looks
like my wife so I beat off to a lot of
Danny Daniels nice pretty she's doing
naughty stuff yeah cuz it's my house my
wife getting like eight bbc's yeah well
that gets me going when I think about
yeah that when you're thinking about
your girl it's your wife is she had a gr
cheese wheel scissors okay yeah yeah
nice nice face alright yeah cuz you
don't realize that a lot of dudes their
faces isn't in it Jeremiah against all
right I got to go do the Jason a lot oh
sorry
I love you Mike no close your big hog Oh
Mike
well my faves he's great at Katherine I
can love that dude he's yeah baby
excellent he's awesome
what do you got so the mayor of a small
town in Peru was hanging out with a
bunch of his friends when police
officers came to break break it up
because of social distancing
restrictions all of his friends decided
to go hide which was the smart thing to
do and he decided to lay there and
pretend like he was dead police officers
took a photo and this is what it this is
what he did well there you go
he just he closed his eyes he tried to
breathe very slowly hey mister that is
the
that's like literally like going you
can't see me fake dead yes Wow
he had to come out and apologize how
about that time here movie cheaters my
bad TV show cheaters guy gets caught you
know what he did when his girl was there
he climbed a tree and wouldn't come down
[Laughter]
calm down he's like this no that's like
you're gonna stay up in that [ __ ]
tree not coming back to reality why I'm
the trio of beer why not treat yourself
okay so I'm pretty sure this video was
taken way before all of the shutdowns
happen but this girl decided to bring
all her family members to the mall and
for some reason she decided she wanted
to propose to him then in there and her
family members had a bunch of posters in
the back she proposed to him in the
middle of the mall he was so embarrassed
that he said no and walked away but I
can't see this small 0kay says no your
works bro he's trying to get her to
stand up
although family he has a bag so he went
shopping before this you have this bag
oh nice oz bag
oh no if families like what where is
this terrible do why are you [ __ ] out
what don't do this no there was no sign
this is public can [ __ ] mall
it does not say but I think this was
taken before kovat oh yeah wants a wife
oh well get up girl yeah I love that the
headline no you're worth gross dude I
can't even watch this stuff I hate it so
much
I hate public displays like that yeah
how would that end the doorman food
court yeah mall dude my friend my
friends pick me up the airport one time
and his girl dressed up like she had
balloons and she dressed up like a like
this real like a skank and was hitting
on me she said they try to flunk me and
I was like and I was like what are you
doing this just what are you doing what
is this joke she feels stupid what is
this terrible joke she feels yeah well
you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
[ __ ] throw my butt for a frank grillo
last night I bring sometimes I open a
bottle of wine and bring it to him you
know so I let sit breathe when I go to
drink yeah he told me sometimes you
bring like half drunk it's not the y'all
bring like some house I bring I'll drink
a little glass of it I'll bring it so so
he and his see he he's there and he
brings me like two glass two bottles of
wine that are like that big seeping out
you drinking and he goes here you go he
said I didn't get the joke let's try
this wine and I was like do you not get
the [ __ ] joke I was like hey Frank
stand now I don't get it but whatever
you old for personal comedian yeah what
are you doing I can't wait to Rose
nothing worse popcorn zoo right over an
empty bag of popcorn yeah this trick in
the den the thing he got arrested using
Google Voice yeah so a kid typed
something out onto Google Translate and
then he plays it while he's on a call
with his dad his dad thinks that his son
is now in jail so it's just a silly
little prank
call from inmate Dustin from Canadian
County Jail dial nine to speak hello
this is a collect call from inmate
Dustin Lee from Canadian County Jail
dial nine to speak oh I was down I was
down at the Campo Park me and Chris are
wakeboarding and these kids came just a
short one yeah how beat your ass yeah
yeah I'll be happy and then this is just
a silly one of a bull dog humping the
groomer perfume he likes like some thick
apparently boy everybody thinking that
right no TLC sits on a pound life in
this pink smells like you don't want man
[ __ ] this Bulldogs - that's cute all
right give us one all right all right
this one my Tyson you did send for weibo
chinese
app I'll play for you there's that
six-pack I mean he's older so I get it
these prizes let's take these oh yeah
Adams
now boys jack what do you say
I'm on weibo now labo it's like it's
it's it's okay I don't know how to
explain it but it's an app to talk the
Evo is kind of like Facebook for China
[Music]
[Music]
because he was really out of shape man
he's jacked so this is how he looked
before yeah yep big I don't know if they
made this photograph a little bit more
sweats he's big it looks great now so
what is he doing is he actually fighting
again I said just maybe for charity yeah
it happens trying to look for a charity
fight possibly Evander Holyfield which
is scary oh my yeah yeah a lot of money
right that's pretty good look at back
then we added so all the shows in
Houston are sold out but we added one on
Thursday which I've been late show on
Thursday which available TV will be
there with us is he will be next week I
don't think it will Friday that's fine
can't work I'm not good I'm doing the
Wilbur theater it's your hometown Boston
you know he goes Boston in January
Boston is cold it's [ __ ] Jimmy I
swear got Jay told me the 29th in yeah I
said it was do you want us dude Sunday I
don't work that I'm just like to get
back on the road man in Houston and then
by the time his pot podcast comes out
there should be innocent Brian and I are
co-headlining Phoenix stand up live
together June 11th rue the 13th
okay that's in Phoenix Arizona where
[ __ ] is popping and then spoken there
actually add in showed a Thursday of
things sold out there Ana show to
Spokane Washington Thursday Brian will
also be with me then Salt Lake City
tickets went on sale that is July 16th
to 18th those are going fast thick boy
bike club we're doing our initial ride
egg nog girl ride and spoken on the 27th
that Saturday when over 150 riders I'm
trying to figure it out and then Salt
Lake City will also be doing a ride at
Beacon Hill Beacon Hills the trail out
there in Salt Lake City sign up now for
the rides at thick boy ride at gmail.com
up for the rides there you go get your
merch thick boy Stevie Stevie blue eyes
Thank You eyes browser's going browsers
soon I'll be there that I'll be
following them around yes somewhere most
and then them love it love it
see you guys mystified kid we're out